Today, I'm going to show you the one
indicator that got me these results in
the last 4 months trading just for 30
minutes and taking only one trade per
day. And before you think this is
another screenshot, let me quickly
refresh this and these are all my stats
verified in real-time. But you know,
most traders who find this indicator
still quit after their first losing
trade and by the end of this video,
you'll understand exactly why and why I
never did. My charts looked back in the
day like a [__] Christmas tree. I
thought more confluence means more
profits. I was losing every single day.
Every indicator was telling me something
different. Buy here, sell here, complete
paralysis. But here is what nobody tells
you. You are not failing because you
don't know enough. You are failing
because you know too much. Then I
deleted everything, kept one indicator,
one time frame, and taking only one
trade per day and this happened. And now
I'll show you exactly what this
indicator is, how to get it for free on
TradingView, when to go long, when to go
short, and most importantly, when to
stay out completely. Here is how to get
it on your chart. You go to indicators,
you select 10 in one moving average.
Then you go to settings, you check the
first three, you put EMA right here, you
put 50 period for all of them, you
select 15 minutes for the first one,
the 30 minutes for the second one, and 1
hour for the third one. Then you choose
whatever color you like.
What this does is to show the higher
time frame EMAs directly on my 5-minute
chart. And now you can see what
institutions see without switching
between multiple time frames. That's how
I define my bias every single day in 5
seconds. If EMAs are stacked and
pointing up, I only go for buys. If EMAs
are stacked and pointing down, I only
going for sales. If EMAs are mixed like
you see here, I don't take a trade at
all. This is the first important step in
my strategy that I used to make these
numbers taking only one trade per day on
NQ using the 5-minute time frame. Now,
let's go to the second step. Since we
are bullish today, we want to see a
bearish counter trend,
and we want to see an fair value gap
inside this bearish counter trend. That
means market is clearly bullish, we need
to see a pullback going down, and we
need to find the fair value gap inside
this counter trend. If you can see,
there is one here. And for the third
step, if we inverse this fair value gap,
that means here we have a bearish fair
value gap. If price breaks through it
and inverse it, we go in, we put our
stop loss either at the previous candle
or at the swing low, we target previous
liquidity or if we don't have a previous
liquidity, we target two hours. Here is
a trade that I took today that played
out really well. Today is the Friday
24th. This is the trade that you've
seen. And every single trade that you
see here in this equity curve was
exactly like this. Now, let me give you
another example. On this day before
market open, we come to the chart, we
see that the EMAs are stacked and
pointing up, my bias will be bullish.
This is the first step. Next, we wait
for the market to open because I always
take trades at the New York session. We
can clearly see a fair value gap right
here inside a counter trend. That means
a pullback against my bias. This is the
second step. Now, for the third step, we
simply wait for the price to breaks
through this fair value gap and to
inverse it.
Now, we can clearly see that this candle
inverse this fair value gap. We go in,
we put our stop loss under the previous
candle because the swing low is far
away, and since we don't have a previous
liquidity that will give us a positive
RR, we'll be targeting a two R.
Now, let's play the price out
and bam,
straight into profits. This is the power
of this setup that repeat itself every
single day and you can take trades like
this every day. Now, let me show you a
day where you shouldn't trade at all. We
can clearly see that the EMAs are
overlapping or mixed. I did the mistake
on the 24th of March of taking a trade
and I did get a loss. Let's play the
price out and show you where I got in. I
said that the price is under the three
EMAs, I will be looking for shorts.
Let's look for a bullish fair value gap.
We can clearly see that we have a
bullish fair value gap right here. I did
go in for short position,
put my stop loss under the previous
swing low, and since we don't have a
near liquidity, I always prefer to
target two hours. Let's play the price
out and let's see this trade.
You see, straight into a stop loss. This
is why I lost this trade on the 24th of
March. Please do not take a trade when
you see that the EMAs are mixed like
this. The EMAs should either be stacked
and pointing up or stacked and pointing
down. If you see that the EMAs are
looking like this, stay away from the
charts. Let's go for another example. On
this market open, we can clearly see
that the EMAs are pointing down, my bias
will be bearish. I will be only looking
for shorts. Let's play the price out
because we always enter after market
open. Let's zoom in.
And since we know our bias, the second
step is to look for a counter trend plus
FVG. The bias is bearish, we have a
clear bullish trend here. This is the
counter trend. We will be looking for a
fair value gap inside this counter
trend. We can see it right here, but we
need the price to close here under the
biggest EMA that you can see right here
to be able to enter this trade. Let's
play the price out.
And now we have an inversion of this
fair value gap. This is the third step.
We enter
for a short, we put our stop loss over
the previous candle, and we will be
targeting this previous liquidity right
here.
Let's play the price out and see what
will happen. This day was the 13th of
March.
And straight into profits. Now, I will
give you the last example from this week
and let's wrap this video up. Before
market open, you can clearly see that
the EMAs are stacked and pointing up, I
will be only looking for longs.
Let's play the price out and let's look
for an FVG in this bearish counter
trend.
We can clearly see that we found an FVG
right here. Now, we will be waiting for
the price to inverse this FVG,
and we will be going long. Entry at the
inversion, stop loss at the previous
candle, we will be targeting two hours
since we don't have a previous liquidity
that is above two hours. Let's play the
price out.
And straight into stop loss. I
deliberately showed you this loss
because I want you to know that this is
not the holy grail. This strategy
brought me 228k
in the last 4 months. This is a textbook
setup, but you will have losses from
times to time. Let me say something.
Here's what complex traders do after
getting stopped out. They change their
rules, add new filters, skip the next
setup, and miss the winner. But here is
what I do. Nothing. Same indicator, same
rules, come back tomorrow, execute the
same exact trade. This is why simple
wins. Trading is like marriage. When it
gets too complex, too many rules, too
many conditions, too many
second-guessing, it fails eventually.
When I stripped everything to one
indicator and three rules, I started
winning consistently. Not because the
indicator is magic, because simplicity
removes hesitation. You see the setup,
you take it every single day. No
confusion, no paralysis, and no
second-guessing. One indicator, three
rules, one trade per day on one time
frame, which is the 5-minute. That's the
whole game. Now, let's do a quick recap.
We trade only on the New York session on
the 5-minute time frame and only NQ. If
the EMAs are stacked pointing up, we go
long. If the EMAs are stacked and
pointing down, we go short. If the EMAs
are mixed and overlapping, we don't
trade at all. This is the first step.
Now, let's say we are bullish today. We
are looking for a fair value gap inside
the counter trend or inside the
pullback, which is opposite to my bias.
This is the second step. Now, if the
price breaks this fair value gap and
invert it, we enter long, we put our
stop loss either at the previous candle
or the previous swing low. You always
put your stop loss where you think the
setup is not viable anymore, either at
the previous candle or the previous
swing low. And the opposite, of course,
goes for short positions. If you have
the previous liquidity that is above two
hours, you go for it. If not, you simply
target two hours. This is the third and
the last step of this strategy. Make
sure to subscribe, like, and drop all
your questions down below in the
comments. I will make sure to answer
every each one of you. Also, don't
forget to follow me on Instagram. See
you on the next one.